[Music]
hey hey it's shake easter and i'm your
host and the founder of casual cattle
conversations a global rancher education
company that strives to bring honest
thoughts and conversations from ranchers
and leaders to other ranchers
be sure to follow cattle combos on
social media to have more in-depth
conversations around the ranching
business and lifestyle brought to you
if you are ready to take your operation
to the next level and improve your
lifestyle too send me a message about my
rancher mine group
rancher mines are monthly roundtable
discussions for ranchers to learn from
peers and experts and leave the call
with actionable advice to make changes
on their own operations
with that let's see who our guest is
today and what experience and advice
they have to offer you to improve your
own operation
well thank you for joining me today i'm
excited to have you on the show i know
this is our first time talking but i
have visited with your brother a little
bit
so to start off would you really share
what your background in the ranching
space is and how you got started
uh thank you for having me shay um
basically
i'm a fifth generation cattle rancher
in the northern part of chihuahua mexico
uh
our family moved here in the
in the
late 1800s early 1900s um and we've been
ranching in this area ever since
going on
almost 100 years now
but
my personal background while i was born
born at the ranch raised at the ranch um
basically this is this is all i know
uh
when i first started actually managing
the ranch i was fresh out of high school
i mean it hasn't been that long
i didn't go to college i didn't i didn't
i didn't really want to go to college so
um
well the ranch was the second best thing
to do
um so
so i started managing the ranch in 2016.
um i'm only 24 years old and well
since then i've i've we've started
with more
intensive grazing practices more
regenerative
grazing practices here at the ranch
and we've been able to
to
maximize our profits
by doing so
how has the conditions of your pastures
changed with these holistic approaches
uh
well we've
been able to to
increase our carrying capacity by three
times uh three times as much so
i mean that gives you an idea the the
quality of forage we have now uh we we
don't give any any protein
i mean it's strictly grass
grass
fed uh beef i mean there's we don't give
any other type of forage just the grass
that we grow um during the winter we
graze all we graze all year round um
and and our area is a semi-arid uh area
we get from anywhere from 15 to 18
inches of rain a year
but we do have uh
some some drought years like in 2020 we
got four inches of rain and we could
still uh double our carrying capacity
with without having
that much rain um
so
as far as our pastures i mean you can
see the difference
in a heartbeat um
and
well the the numbers are there to show
to show that this type of management
actually works and i mean it's
for a ranch in this area to to
to
run as much cattle as as we do it's
i mean it's
it's one
one in a hundred so
um
i mean
that's
our
we've seen the benefits
so what is your like stocking right now
or what does your carrying capacity look
like now that you you said you've
increased the amount of cattle you can
run by three times
so what does that look like for you
in this area
people usually run from 12 hectares 12
to 15 hectares per cow per year
we use the metric system in mexico acres
would be about
roughly 20 acres per cow per year
and we're running three hectares per cow
per year which is roughly about seven
acres per cow per year wow
so what what are your forage types there
what are some of those um native forages
uh we
we mostly we have perennial
uh grasses uh blue grama black drama red
grama
uh
there's we we've counted up to 20
different types of species here at the
at the ranch i mean they're all mostly
all perennials we have very very very
little annuals um
the high quality forages that keep their
protein year round and and with the
right rest period it it really helps
the cattle eat a better diet
when when
when you have
i mean
stockpiled forages it helps their
nutrition like you can't imagine
so there are
multiple different ways to implement
regenerative practices when you look at
grazing what models are you looking at
i'm sure you've kind of adapted it to
your own ranch and what works as many
people do but
really when you say you are implementing
regenerative practices what does that
look like for you on a daily basis
um
here at the ranch we have over 500 packs
give or take the five
all those 500 products we
we make them uh year round with poly
wire everything we use is portable
so
it has our our
our infrastructure is so portable we can
pick up and move wherever we
and at a very low cost
so
we build over 500 paddocks a year we
move daily sometimes we even four or
five times a day
so it's highly intensive so we can get
the best out of the
out of our forage uh use it properly and
and rest it properly also inside of
those 500 paddocks
we have a
rotation of about 425 days of rest per
paddock
so i mean our
per paddock we have a
a time period
we use it
maybe six hours per for every 420 days
so our our rest period is
is is
is what's making this work
wow so
you talked about how you're constantly
on the move moving cattle how many
employees how many people do you have
working on your operation to manage this
workload then
um it's only me and
i have one hired hand
but
other than that we're running i mean in
between me and my hired help we're
running over 500 cows
and and we have
about 200 stalkers here at the ranch you
know so there's a there's there's quite
a bit of work but i mean
when you're organized and since you move
them every single day it cuts down on
your on on
basically
uh
checking the cattle health-wise since
you see them every day i mean it
it simplifies everything most people
think because of moving once a day it's
going to be a lot more difficult but
honestly
it's a lot simpler than moving
moving every 15 days or every 20 days
and and your paddocks are a lot smaller
so it's easy to get around your paddocks
with poly wire
in a day and just just keep it portable
keep it simple and well i don't have
that much help
we have
we have a well organized
uh
ranch
well-fueled ranch
i guess
so what are some
processes you've implemented to make
putting up that poly wire faster easier
just make the whole process more
efficient
um
what we usually do is is make
instead of having like your typical
wagon wheel or
or having uh
something permanent
uh basically we go with the what our
land gives us so all our our all our
fences
go off of the terrain
most of our our ranch is flat so
basically we just build a
small squares and then we have water in
every single paddock so
the water
it's all piped we have a
pipeline a two inch pipeline that goes
throughout the ranch and from there when
we're grazing the animals we can connect
uh our portable water trough to to
wherever we need
wherever we need the pipe
so the water for cattle
so with that
you know
do you do any like
you know lease out any recreation
activities on the ranch or do anything
on that front um in addition to this or
do you just i mean is it just are you a
commercial operation what does that look
like for you guys
uh
basically it's it's a commercial
operation what we do what basically it's
cow calf
and
once we wean our calves we export them
to the us
so we export live cattle to the us
other recreational
activities we do there's a little bit of
hunting
i mean whitetail hunting uh
uh
turkeys
um but other than that it's it's purely
just cattle path so we might run a
little stalkers here and there but um
basically just
okay so have these grazing practices
benefited have you seen a large benefit
in the amount of wildlife present the
availability of hunting on your ranch
yeah for sure i mean what what's
happening we're basically building a
micro climate here at the ranch that is
helping
is helping us
with all types of wildlife biodiversity
where we also work with a lot of
conservation services uh basically any
migratory birds that come to our ranch
it's it's a conservation so we we can uh
take care of of
those animals that that need need that
habitat
and uh
we've been working with uh the rocky
mountain bird
con
conservancy for the past four years i
think
and uh basically what they do is take
care of if all the migratory
bird species that come from from the
rockies down to the down to mexico
and uh that that's a big part of our
our our goal here at the ranch to to at
least leave what what we have better
than we than when we got in
i think that's an awesome point to leave
things better than when you found them
and something a lot of ranchers try to
do
so with that kind of looking back at
you know the types of practices you're
using you know what resources do you go
to to continue your learning you know
what did that process look like as you
got started who did you turn to for
advice
uh
first i i turned to my dad obviously he
he was
when the holistic management movement
came to mexico he was one of the first
pioneers so
i turned to my dad a lot and and
also the savory institute helps a lot
and
ranching for profit i'm a
love of x alumni from wrenching for
profit which it help helps a lot when
you're trying to run a business that
well it's it's
it's
you're running a business off of what
nature gives you um
and and you're trying to manage you're
trying to manage resources that
that
that can be
be
bettered uh improved
um
knowing how to do it is is key and i
mean here
fortunately here in mexico in chihuahua
where there's quite a
quite a few people that are practicing
uh regenerative agriculture gender
ranching whatever you want to call it
there's a lot of people here in
chihuahua in my state that um
that are actually doing it and basically
what we
we we all have a group chat we just
bounce ideas off of each other but
um
any any type of thing you want to learn
i highly recommend to to take courses
and and
and learn about it
well that's exciting so
what mindset do ranchers need to have
when they are
starting to get into regenerative
grazing and really embrace that style of
ranch management
i think they need to change the paradigm
first i mean
there's a lot of uh misconceptions of
branching especially here in chihuahua a
lot of people think it's too dry it
can't be done here
but they're just all paradigms you need
you need to change and and once once you
start actually
uh moving daily and get the hang of it
there's no better way to actually do it
than doing it and and
i mean your failures are going to be
they're going to be
um
what's it called
they're going to be
it's going to be like your school i mean
it's going to teach you how what not to
do
um
but
uh just changing your paradigms the way
you think is it helps has
has a lot to do with uh
running a ranch this way
well awesome do you have any
last advice for those who are interested
in improving their grazing methods or
any last comments you'd like to share
before we finish up today
yeah i mean a lot of people get stuck on
on yeah i want to do the change and but
they don't know how to
start the change
um
i would recommend
getting
getting a consultant having someone
consult you for so so you don't make the
same mistakes like i did or
anyone else did
and
uh
yeah some people might say the
consultants are
are expensive or they charge too much
but
he'll give you a helping hand once you
start
and then once you're once you have a
consultant then then i i highly
recommend uh
keeping everything portable
i mean there's no sense in in dumping a
bunch of money when
when you can actually do it with
portable poly wire portable posts
so so you're gonna basically be changing
one thing for another you're gonna be
changing sweat for
an improvement or or changing money for
for
infrastructure so i i highly recommend
just
making everything portable
the more portable you have it the more
flexibility you have to graze wherever
you can or or
in points of opportunity throughout your
ranch
um but other than that i mean
just
it's time to change the way we think and
it's time to change the way we ranch
well awesome thank you very much for
joining me today i'm excited to share
this with my audience and appreciate all
that you had to share
thank you for having me shane and that's
a wrap on that one be sure to let me
know your thoughts on the episode and if
you have any further questions around
the topic take care and have a great day
you